what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talked about some of the best revenge
moments an anime again I said that if we
got 3,000 likes on the best revenge
moments in anime part 2 then I'd make up
part 3 and we got well over 3,000 likes
so here I am with part 3 as promised
this time I thought that we make it a
bit harder if we can hit 4,000 likes on
this video then I will get started on
part 4 ASAP make sure to leave some of
your favorite revenge moments in and
mate in the comments and they may appear
in the next installment if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and ring that
notification bell because if you don't
you won't get notified when the next
installment drops keep in mind there
will be spoilers in this video if that
actually bothers you now without further
ado let's jump into it since the new
season of seven deadly sins is currently
airing let's start with Mele Otis's
savage revenge moment against fraud Rijn
to fully appreciate this moment we have
to go back some 16 years fraud Rijn
escaped his seal and killed millio das's
love liz who was the most important
person in his life at the time if we
know anything about Mele öitís is that
he cares a lot about his elizabeth's he
even understands when bond tries to kill
him in the hopes that it will bring
Alain back Mele Otis completely
understands how bond could be willing to
kill his best friend if it means that he
could save the love of his life so it's
not surprising that when he sees Roger
and murder liz his lover he loses it at
the time his wrath took over and he
wiped the city of Dan afar off the face
of the earth yet Roger managed to
survive now fast forward to when Mele
Otis F Roger and meet again 16 years
later Roger and who was Andreas his body
has revealed this true form
he is absolutely huge in the manga
Dreyfus appears to be the size of
projects foot that's how much this
monster towers over everyone just as
fraudulence says he's going to crush
everyone in one go he gets hit in the
face then he keeps getting hit over and
over while everyone is trying to figure
out what's going on well soon enough we
see meliodas extremely small frame
Mellie Otis was even smaller and Dreyfus
was the one who was hitting the giant
frog turn around
Rajan looks completely powerless against
them despite his size it's like if
something the size of an ant was kicking
your butt Rajan says that mili Otis the
strength is no match for his now he says
let's finish what we started 16 years
ago
reminding Mellie Otis of Liz's death at
this point to Hauser it seems like the
two are about equally matched in power
the Mellie Otis that is fighting
froderick has a combat class of thirty
thousand while Rajan has a combat class
of thirty one thousand so they are
pretty close
however as Merlin notices this wasn't
Mellie Otis at his full power actually
this was just one of his doppelgangers
and Mellie owned Estelle's fraud Hren
that he held his own pretty well against
his clone at this point fraud Rinna's
shocked and extremely worried Mellie
Otis's actual resting power level right
now is sixty thousand and it's even
greater in his demon form meliodas
purposely misled froderick to make his
revenge all the sweeter as he tells
fraudulent who's sweating buckets at
this point
seeing your face go from hope to despair
makes me feel on top of the world and
quote so he didn't have to toy with
Roger in the beginning but he wanted to
break him mentally and not just
physically he got his hopes up only so
that he could crush them then Mellie
Otis smiles his wicked demon smile dark
aura is radiating off of him and his
demon mark is showing on his forehead he
went from innocent looking to evil
looking real quick
Mellie Otis tells Roger that he'll wipe
out every last trace of him from the
earth Mellie Otis puts countless holes
into fraud rein in a moment it's so bad
that the giant fraud recalls Mellie Otis
a monster he begins to shrink
he tells malleolus that's a demon clan
impatiently waited for revenge against
the goddess fan and against Mellie Otis
for abandoning the Ten Commandments
Mellie Otis says he's the same way he
also impatiently waited to get revenge
against fraud Rijn because of what he
did to Liz he Slavs fraud Rijn and sent
him flying and Mellie Otis tells fragra
not to go dying on him yet even bond who
was smiling a moment ago is not
concerned he notices this is Emilio
toises usual way of fighting
Mellie Otis even goes after fraudulent
pride when fraudulent claims that he is
one of the demon Lords chosen commandant
Molly Otis tells him that he wasn't
given a commandment by the demon lord
he's nothing more than a stand-in Rajan
loses it and starts a self-destruct
Mellie Otis continues to smile and
despite wanting to Rajan can't wipe
melioidosis smirk off his face
he says he'll wipe Leonys from the map
and all the people there will perish but
Mellie Otis does not give him the
desired reaction at all he just says if
you're going to die
make it quick you're
putting me to sleep here and quote fraud
sure is about to take Dreyfus with him
but Gris amore hugs froderick he creates
an energy field around him and begs
fraud run with tears in his eyes not to
kill anyone
fraud run despite being a demon has
developed feelings for Gris amore as if
he was his own son he can't stand to
hurt him so he stops the detonation he
tells the boy to let down the energy
wall and go to his dad with a compassion
look on his face then he tells malleolus
to kill him you might think that
malleolus would have been touched by
frogs and selfless compassion for grill
Moray but he's not at all with a big
satisfied smile on his face he wipes
away fraud's body with one ruthless
punch without any hesitation afterwards
even Merlin arguably one of the most
immoral characters in the series can't
help but think that that was an ugly way
to take out progerin despite everything
he's done this revenge moment had years
and even millennia behind it it had the
most powerful motivation behind it
firmly Otis because frogs and killed the
woman he loved
it made Mellie Otis our happy-go-lucky
Shana protagonist look more evil and
cruel than the enemy for a second it was
so ruthless that even Merlin and bond
who hates most demons for what they did
to Elaine thought Mellie Otis went too
far for all these reasons this moment
stands out as one of the most powerful
revenge moments in all of anime next
let's mix it up and look at a less
savage yet still awesome revenge moment
this Demon Slayer moment that I'm about
to mention more so reminds me of when
luffy punched the celestial dragon then
a premeditated and long-awaited revenge
this moment happens right after Tanja is
brought in from the pillars the
strongest and most respected members of
the Demon Slayer Corps Tundra is tied up
and he's on trial for helping a demon
his sister Nez ago rather than killing
her that's when the seemingly biggest
jerk pillar of all time shows up the
wind pillar she knows Ogawa sana me
after all Tundra twas been through with
his sister Sena me comes in holding the
box now circle is in and calling our
protagonist an idiot as if this wasn't
bad enough son of me tells him that it's
impossible to work with a demon this
whole time Tundra has been working
towards healing his sister that was why
he became a Demon Slayer and here this
high ranking member is calling his goals
idiotic and saying
they're impossible not only that in
addition to calling tundra [ __ ] he
stabs nezha code through the box that's
right he stabs the cutest girl in all of
anime at this point we are all rooting
for Tangier oh and especially for the
beyond cute Natsuko everyone on the
internet wants to protect her and yet
this guy is hurting her
the mangaka has made it all but
impossible not to hate this pillar at
this point that's when Tonto rushes ATS
enemy screw the fact that he's tied up
screw the fact that he's on trial screw
the fact that he's surrounded by pillars
and screw the rules as he runs autonomy
he says I will never forgive anybody
pillar or whatever who hurts my little
sister sodomy is amused he's confident
his abilities he's much stronger than
Tundra after all he goes 2/10 general
but Tonto jumps over it and lands a
glorious headbutt of revenge on Sunna me
blood shoots from the confidence enemy's
face and he falls to the ground does
time to apologize after realizing what
he's done not at all he actually
lectures the higher ranking and stronger
pillar he tells him that if he can't
tell the good demons from the bad ones
then he should quit being a pillar the
previously amused pillar is now
extremely upset Sena me says he'll rip
Tonto to shreds but the leader of the
demon Slayers shows up before he gets
the chance this is not a conventional
revenge moment but it is deeply
satisfying nonetheless the fact is that
Tonto like Luffy doesn't conform to
societal pressures he knows what's right
and what's wrong and he will break any
rule in order to do the right thing in
this case the right thing was
head-butting sodomy and embarrassing him
in front the other pillars despite his
high ranking status is Tundra concerned
about the fact that he's already on
trial and should therefore be on his
best behavior not at all he doesn't care
about what others will think but he does
care about protecting his sister and his
dreams this moment does a great job of
giving us a better sense of what kind of
character Tantra is and it doesn't hurt
that the pillar jerk paid for hurting
our precious as we go either lastly
we're going to be looking at the epic
Jotaro from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
this is one of my favorite Avenger
moments of all time and that speaks to
the talent of the mangaka
because he builds up the thirst for
revenge so quickly compared to some
other works while some works have
revenge moments that build up over the
whole series the revenge
between Jotaro and Steely Dan was only
given about two anime episodes to build
up however it's done in such a way that
the revenge moment is as satisfying as
if Giotto had suffered decades of
wrongdoing from Steely Dan so the idea
is that Steely Dan has a stand a special
power which lets him tie his own pain to
that of another individual except the
pain is amplified you punch him in the
face and the person who is tied to him
will experience an even more painful
punched in the face sensation Steely Dan
uses his stand on Joseph Joestar
jotaro's grandpa thus if Jorah is to
hurt Steely Dan or if Dan is to hurt
himself Joseph would experience that
much more pain he could even die from it
so that is what's going on Steely Dan
has taken Joe to knows grandpa hostage
and he is using that to hurt in the mean
Joe taro in any way he can think of this
is all the more impactful because Joe
taro is such a cool guy he always seems
to be the coolest person in the room he
has that James Bond image going on so
imagine James Bond being asked to lick
someone's shoe and you get a sense of
what's happening here now let's jump
into the details from the beginning this
encounter is hilarious Steely Dan tries
to act so cool when Jorah threatens to
punch him he just says please you cannot
touch me and then the next scene is Joe
toasts and punching the crap out of him
you see Steely Dan was expecting that
Jotaro would let him finish and explain
that he is connected to his grandfather
but it's just so funny that Joe turtle
suddenly interrupted him with an attack
after he was so cocky about being
untouchable that was truly one of the
funniest moments to me so here are some
of the things Steely Dan did he
obviously connected to Joseph's body and
heard him many times his stand also
eventually devours a person's brain so
he was close to killing Joseph he
actually made Jotaro sweat in the
beginning which is rare since he is
usually calm cool and collected Dan hits
a kid after he helped him he taunts Joe
Tyrell begging him to hit him in his
face or open a hole in his chest
Jotaro needs to be calmed down multiple
times by his friends in the beginning
Steely Dan punches jutted on the stomach
knowing he can't do anything back he
hits him with a rock - Jota puts up with
this and simply tells Dan that he will
pay Dan is completely confident though
at this point he continues to mess with
he uses Jotaro as a human bridge to
cross a ditch he makes him scratch his
back he makes him wipe his shoes only to
kick him in the face despite all this
Jotaro somehow gets calmer and calmer as
the story goes on he is seen at one
point writing in a notebook when asked
about it he explains that he is writing
down everything Steely Dan will get
payback for he is writing it down
because he is forgetful he explains with
a smile this part is absolutely amazing
because Steely Dan is supposed to be in
complete control of the situation he has
all the power and yet jotaro's acting
calm cool and collected even as he's
getting hit and Dan looks worried Steely
Dan goes on to make Joe to break the law
he makes him steal a bracelet only to
rat on him to the owners afterwards then
Jotaro gets beaten up by three grown men
as Dan steals jewels to his heart's
content you'd think that Giotto would be
upset he just got framed for stealing
beaten up and told to leave the country
even with blood pouring down his face he
smiles though he starts to laugh even
then asks what he's laughing about and
Joseph explains that he's anticipating
the payback when the team finally kicks
Steely Dan's stand out of Joseph's brain
Joe tanto starts messing with Dan Dan
starts to run away but Jethro catches
him and asked why he is in such a hurry
Dan quickly flips and starts to admit
defeat to Joe at all he reveals his
calmness confidence and pride was an act
that was completely tied to favourable
circumstances he licks Jotaro shoe and
begs for his own life in the most
pathetic way possible however he still
plans on trying to trick Joe he plans to
use his stand on him he's just acting
like he accepts the feet to buy time it
is clear that he is a man who possesses
no honor at all Joe toe catches Steely
Dan stand with his own stand and starts
to crush it
he breaks Dan's arm and leg in the
process Judas says that the arm and the
leg were payment for all the things he
did to him he starts to walk away giving
Dan hope for a third time
Dan not knowing when to quit tries to
take over a nearby girl thinking that
Joe total won't risk hurting the girl he
approaches Joe total to stab him but Joe
Torre's dad calm he just says go ahead
and do it then he grabs Dan's hand and
use it to cut Dan's face he reveals that
his friend kakyoin has trapped Steely
Dan's
and he never had any intention of
letting dangle so easy then offers Joe
throw all the money deal gave him but
Joe Thoreau calls him the worst man in
the history of mankind and explains that
the debt he owes can't be bought with
money in the manga Joe tiller goes on to
punch Dan with his stand for almost four
full pages straight if you read manga
you know that this is a lot of space in
a chapter usually when there's one full
page dedicated to something it's a huge
deal but this is virtually unprecedented
it's also awesome in the anime but the
length it gets in the manga is extremely
satisfying as if that wasn't that big
enough Joe Thoreau done signs his name
and rips out a page from his notebook
saying and here is your receipt he
throws it on the ground and walks away
like a boss this is one of my favorite
moments in anime after initially being
upset and losing his cool Joe Turner
quickly accepts the reality of the
situation and remains calm and even
amused as Dan continues to hurt and
demean him no matter how much Dan tries
to tarnish Jethro's cool-guy image he
can't do it because Joe Terra won't give
him the reaction Dan is looking for Dan
gets more upset than Jotaro even though
Joe Thoreau is the one taking all the
damage
unlike Dan Joe Tyrone never breaks down
or starts begging the revenge moment is
even better because just little calmly
told Dan that he would get payback early
on in the encounter despite how unlikely
it seemed at the time and things went
exactly how he said they would perhaps
after this you can better understand why
Joe taro is my favorite Joe Joe and why
this is one of my favorite Avenger
moments in anime and that is it for
today's video thank you so much for
watching if you did enjoy this video
remember to drop a like if we can get
4000 likes I'll get started on the next
one
ASAP make sure to leave some of your
favorite bench moments in anime in the
comments and they may appear in the next
installment if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and ringed I notification
about because if you don't you won't get
notified when the next installment drops
for more anime content updates follow us
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who help make videos
like this one possible I especially want
to thank our pro here to your patrons
the one and only gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson King's August angel
Cruz Steelers papa
a triple straight $30.00 beat Akagi and
Anatole Cassatt's key DJ Nathaniel and
alpha do and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans
Steven and rata al-hola Optum mad evac
239 makoto-kun and ya boy set if you
enjoy our work you can support more of
it by going over to patreon commodore
and becoming a patron today for as
little as one dollar if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/lenguin
[Music]
no matter what way you choose to support
us you'll get the same great benefits
anyways thanks again for everything and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]